leadership is about what the Army taught
me five C's
the first C is courage
people want to see a courageous person
they want to see a courageous leader the
second C is competence
because as you know no one follows a
dummy into a firefight so they want to
know they have a competent leader the
next C is commitment a commitment to a
core set of principles and values I mean
you can say what you want about Ronald
Reagan but you know he was committed to
America he was committed to the
Constitution he was committed to our
fundamental principles and values then
you got to be convicted that's the
fourth C because even when the winds
blow the polls say this whatever you got
to stay true north leaders stay true
north they committed to something and
they're convicted to and then the last
thing is character doing what is right
when no one's watching that's what I
taught soldiers that's what I taught my
daughter's five C's courage competence
commitment conviction and character